I was outside a bar in New York City
and my phone was stolen out from my hand
within three minutes I was locked out of
my own Apple ID and within 24 hours I
noticed that there were thousands of
dollars being taken out of my bank
account
you've been reaching out to me with
stories like this
their iPhones are stolen and all the
protections and security they thought
they had
didn't matter bank accounts emptied
credit cards opened no more access to
photos contacts and anything in their
iCloud their digital lives gone how
It All Leads back to the theft of the
iPhone's passcode it turns out that code
that can unlock your phone can also help
someone else unlock your entire Digital
Life you lose your phone you don't think
about how you can lose everything else
I'm a good Apple customer I back
everything up to iCloud and I thought I
would come back home log in on my
MacBook and everything just would be
fine that's not what happens once you
take over someone's Apple ID it's game
over for them after months of reporting
I've been able to break down how these
attacks are happening and how you can
better protect yourself
at least until better protections exist
at a bar
at night that's where many of these
stories begin I was distracted and then
the phone was gone he was next to me he
grabbed the phone and disappeared rayon
ias's story is similar to many others in
New York and around the country but it's
1300 miles away from New York that
they've pinned down what's happening
investigators say thieves work together
to steal phones then use apps to take
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
Minneapolis 12 people have been charged
in a phone robbery ring where nearly
three hundred thousand dollars had been
taken from at least 40 victims
this is the arrest warrant for one of
the people accused in that scheme it
says the group targeted bargoers Often
by befriending them and then transferred
large sums of money via various
financial apps on the stolen phones so I
tracked down Sergeant Robert oleshko
hello the lead investigator on the case
to find out more about how these thieves
got into the phones
enter their their passcodes into the
phone to some suspects will act in a
coordinated group there'll be one
suspect who might be
actually obtaining
the enter in the past do you think
there's a chance you put in your
passcode that night potentially yeah
and that's why the entirety of football
security cannot hinge on those six
digits similar crimes have been reported
in Austin Denver Boston and London and
in New York Rayhan is amongst hundreds
of victims according to people familiar
with the investigations some victims in
those cities say they believed they were
drugged before their phone was taken
when I reached out to Apple for comment
here's what they said we sympathize with
users who have had this experience and
we take all attacks on our users very
seriously no matter how rare the thefts
described are uncommon and require
multiple physical steps stealing a
user's device is not enough we will
continue to advance the protections to
help keep user accounts secure but can
an iPhone passcode really unlock your
entire financial and personal life Let's
Pretend This is rayhan's iPhone 13
Promax and the thieves observed to the
passcode in every story I've heard the
thieves very first step was to change
the Apple ID password to lock the owners
out this way they could turn off find my
iPhone so the phone couldn't be located
you realize your phone has been stolen
what do you what do you do next at the
bar I log into find my iPhone on my
friend's phone right away I wasn't able
to do that because in the three minutes
that had passed my Apple ID password
which I'm absolutely sure of by the way
was changed to change the Apple ID
password on an iPhone all someone has to
do is go to settings tap the iCloud name
then password and security and change
password then you're prompted for yes
the iPhone's passcode input it and you
can create a new passcode for the Apple
ID and the thief can then use that to
turn off find my iPhone with the
passcode they can log the owner out of
their other trusted devices like iPads
and Macs change the trusted phone number
and add something called a recovery key
adjusting all that can further lock you
out of your account potentially forever
I've had my MacBook for way too long I'm
almost embarrassed to say it on camera
honestly and it's it's locked out I
tried every Avenue through Apple support
then I realized the bank transactions
and that's when it hit me that this is
Way Beyond just a petty phone theft
after the Apple account it's on to the
money all eight of the victims I spoke
with said they had thousands of dollars
taken in the first 24 hours after the
theft I saw that they transferred some
money from my savings account to my
checking account and then I took a whole
bunch in the form of Apple cash
when you say a whole bunch how much
about ten thousand dollars how do they
get the money rayan and others I spoke
with had the passwords to their Bank
apps saved in Apple's built-in password
manager
so when you go to a bank app the
software tells you the password is saved
all you need is a face ID scan or yes
the phone's passcode to get in and if
the app requires a text message code to
confirm it's really you well the thieves
already have your phone they go after
other financial apps too venmo coinbase
Zell I've heard them all and they can
use Apple pay because that just needs
the passcode too
so I got the email that an Apple car
titanium has been approved in my name
and shortly afterwards I also got some
receipts some charges of like five
thousand dollars thieves open those
Apple credit cards using a victim's
social security number which may be
found in photos of documents stored on
the phone what about Android
of all the cases that have investigated
that 99 of the cell phones that are
stolen
have been iPhones and not Android do you
have a sense of why that is
that said the passcode can do a lot of
the same in Google's operating system
most of people who had their phone
stolen got the money back by filing
fraud reports with the banks and other
Financial companies
but some of them remain locked out of
their apple accounts unable to access
years of photos notes contacts
recordings and more I've been using
um iCloud for 15 years for them to store
my memories and keep them safe
and they're all gone
and being told permanently that I've
lost all of those memories have been
very hard an apple spokeswoman said that
the company's account recovery policies
are in place to protect users from
unauthorized access to their accounts
while reporting this story I've been
really freaked out by all of this
when you look at this board and see how
a short string of numbers can unravel
your whole Digital Life you realize it's
time to do something more at least until
Apple figures out some solutions to this
vulnerability so I'm going to ask you to
do three things to protect yourself the
same three things I've done on my own
iPhone
make your passcode stronger
go to settings face ID and passcode and
make it at least six digits even better
make it an alphanumeric code treat it
like an ATM pin
on some financial apps such as venmo you
can go to the app's settings to enable
additional passcode protection just
don't pick the same passcode as your
phone of course using face ID and touch
ID will also help you avoid using your
passcode in public next rethink your
password manager
go to settings passwords and remove any
passwords and login info to the banks
and other financial apps on your iCloud
keychain
for now you're better off with a
third-party password manager that
requires a separate password for Access
finally delete photos with sensitive
personal information go to photos and
delete images of your driver's license
passport tax forms Etc
keep them in a password protected
third-party password manager instead yes
there's more that you can do but there's
also more that Apple can do to lessen
the power of the passcode which right
now can unlock pretty much everything in
your life